there's a recent report that indicates that
71% of antisemitic incidents in the United
States last year were committed by right wingers,
which I don't think comes as a surprise. Uh,
it comes as a surprise to most people and
this came up during my debate about free speech
with Tim Pool on our youtube channel earlier
this week, which by the way is now archived
on youtube. I encourage you to watch it. There's
some uh, interesting stuff in there. Uh, and
it's important to understand that not all
antisemitism is on the right, but according
to Anti Defamation League data, about 71%
of antisemitic incidents last year were committed
by right wingers also.
Not surprisingly, there's a new report out
which exposes that there are neo Nazi networks
within the United States military. This also
is not going to be a surprise to many people.
Independent media outlet Unicorn riot published
and investigation, which found that there
are 11 specific members of a group called
identity Europa, Europa with a, with a v instead
of a you as the second letter, which is a
Neo Nazi organization. It's operating in the
u s military and there are specific members
that they know of who are currently in the
United States Military Unicorn riot. And huffpost
found that plenty of people who spend their
free time posting antisemitic memes and praising
Adolf Hitler on the Internet currently are
members of the United States military. And
now the investigation is actually named some
names and some of the individuals are relatively
high ranking ranking, including a lieutenant
colonel who's a doctor in the army reserves.
As one example. And a few months ago at the
end of 2018, propublica did their own investigation
and exposed that there's another neo Nazi
network with members in the military. It's
a group called the Adam Waffen Division, uh,
which focused on or focuses on recruiting
on college campuses and distributing flyers.
And members of the Adam Waffen division have
been implicated in five murders in the last
two years. Now, some of their members have
been tied to plots to bomb synagogues and
nuclear power plants and they have active
members who are currently in the United States
military. And none of this really is news,
right? There was a poll from the military
times a few years ago where 25% of military
members said they encountered white nationalism
in the ranks. And that number is probably
higher. But I would understand that there
are probably some people in the military that
don't want to admit that they've encountered
white nationalism in the military.
So it might seem sort of obvious that an organization
that lets you carry guns, it might let you
go to war. Maybe you'd get to kill people
that that would attract violent fascist elements
of society. So in a sense it is obvious, but
it's not just the military that's at qissue.
It's really a cultural issue. And what I mean
by that is if you look at other countries,
yes, the military is a job where you carry
guns and maybe you get to kill people and
that's more likely to appeal to violent fascist
elements. But the culture surrounding war
and masculinity and all of these other issues
works as a sort of exacerbating factor in
the United States where you have a huge contingent
that supports aggressive foreign policy. You've
got the problem of our relationship to guns.
You have lack of access to mental health that
you have right now.
A president who's rhetoric has inflamed this
type of violent ideology. So of course you
end up with a military that contains these
extreme elements. And my point is, even if
the military in some general way, is more
likely to attract people predisposed to violence
or to wanting to, to have the opportunity
to maybe kill people or shoot people, it doesn't
actually have to be as bad as it is in the
United States. The military does provide opportunities
to people who might be lacking opportunities,
but it also provides opportunities to people
with a masculinity complex to people who have
these extreme beliefs in their country's supremacy
or their race's supremacy and to the military's
credit in the US, they do have formal prohibitions
against service members participating in these
groups. Of course they don't, they don't catch
everybody. And that's really the issue. Um,
we have enough problems with the engagements
that our presidents choose to involve our
military and we don't also need to aggravate
that with extremist fascists inside of the
service. And the results of this study are
very, very concerning.